أجنبي
مثل دراغستر، يقوم طاقم اللواء
الميكانيكي الثامن والعشرون بتسخين دبابة
T-64 التي تعود إلى الحقبة السوفيتية للمعركة،
لدينا مشاكل مع الذخيرة، نحن على
وشك النفاد، أخبرني القائد
وهذه هي المشكلة الوحيدة التي لدينا، حيث نحصل على ما
يكفي من قطع الغيار التي يعملها قادتنا
طوال الوقت للحفاظ على الدبابة وإصلاحها، يقوم
القائد الذي يمر بعلامة النداء
ديفيد بسباق الوحش البالغ من العمر 40 عامًا
نحو خط المواجهة مثل
قطار المحرك البخاري، والعديد من
الدبابات القتالية الرئيسية في أوكرانيا قديمة مثل هذه،
ولهذا السبب  يقول الجيش إنهم
بحاجة ماسة إلى تلك الدبابات القتالية الغربية الرئيسية الجديدة التي
يقولون إنها تتراوح ما بين ثلاثمائة إلى
أربعمائة لمحاولة تغيير مجرى الأمور في
هذه الحرب.
المشكلة هي أن أوكرانيا تنفد من
الدبابات التي تعود إلى الحقبة السوفيتية وتواجه
مشكلة متزايدة في استبدال تلك المفقودة
في المعركة أو التي تحتاج إليها.
ساعدت الإصلاحات الثامنة والعشرون في تحرير ابنها في
الجنوب ثم تم إرسالها إلى هنا، لقد
كانت حرب طويلة بالفعل لهذه الوحدة.
الجنود الأوكرانيون على الجبهة حول
باكمود مبتهجون، ترسل الدول الغربية
دبابات قتالية حديثة من طراز m1a2 أبرامز
من طراز ليوبارد توينز الأمريكي الألماني الصنع.
ودبابات تشالنجر البريطانية
ولكن الأوكرانيين أيضًا ماهرون في
استخدام الدبابات السوفيتية القديمة، لديهم الآن
أفضل تأثير
لإطلاق النار وإعادة التحميل
بالتصويب
وإطلاق النار بسرعة مرة أخرى على
مهندس الدبابة الذي ذكر اسمه فقط
هو ماكسيم، ويقول إن الجنود من الفرقة
28 يمكنهم تشغيل هذه المركبات
معصوب العينين،
إذا أطلقنا النار من موقع مغطى،
نستخدم هذا الجهاز، يقول إنه قديم
وتناظري ولكنه فعال للغاية ودقيق للغاية.
وتقول القوات الأوكرانية إن دباباتها
كانت مهمة للغاية وفعالة
هنا في باحمود في مواجهة
مرتزقة شركة فاغنر العسكرية الروسية الخاصة
الذين غالبًا ما يستخدمون  المحكوم عليهم
كوقود للمدافع لمحاولة اقتحام
المواقع الأوكرانية بدون دعم ناري تقريبًا،
يقول قائد الدبابة إنهم
يعملون باستمرار لوقف
تقدم فاغنر هنا ولكن فقط نقاتلهم
إذا توقفنا فسوف يقتربون
وسنفقد منازلنا
وعائلاتنا  قف هنا للسماح للناس
بالعيش بسلام في منازلهم ولكن
الجيش الأوكراني يتعرض لضغوط متزايدة
حول باكموت حيث يقوم الروس بصب المزيد من
الدروع في هذه المنطقة،
ربما لن تصل الدبابات الغربية الموعودة بالسرعة
الكافية لإحداث فرق في هذه
المعركة
ولكن هؤلاء الجنود  وأعربوا عن أملهم في أن يحولوا
دفة الحرب